this video represent 100% fact and it's
not at all in opinion if you disagree
with this video that's merely implies
that you are misaligned with reality or
miss a decade own facts if the former I
suggest a psychiatrist the latter eyes
are just watching this video let's start
this up the piano is the greatest
instrument ever and I'm going to give
you five reasons why number one most
instruments like The Voice wind and
brass instruments can only play one note
at a time this means to even play simple
pieces these instruments require you to
have several friends to play with
let's piano you can forego all of that
and play several make at the same time
which is one of the main reasons it's
the most popular single instrument
I mean solo instrument number two a lot
of instruments take a ton of practice
just to create a good sound like trumpet
or violin which leads everyone with an
ear shot to hate you while you practice
with just one press the canadough anyone
for a reasonable sound so even though
the piano is incredibly tough to master
at least people won't hate you while you
do it number three the layout is
intuitive now I know this might sound
confusing to some of you who look at the
piano like I might look at the Chinese
menu but trust me compared to some of
these monstrosity the piano is really
easy to understand all you really have
to know is the pitch of these notes go
up in ascending order low to high what
your brain expects is exactly how its
laid out this is always higher than
anything below it add to this the fact
that the piano is a very visual
instrument and this makes it the perfect
learning tool this is why if you
seriously study any instrument you will
at some point be asked to pick up a
little bit of piano on the side in order
to help you understand music theory
number four Weatherby Chopin Bach or
Billy Joel the overwhelming majority of
great composers play piano number five
check this up
[Music]
now that's a pretty compelling reason to
learn sex but actually it was played on
a keyboard aka and like piano using what
is called a virtual instrument these are
becoming more common in some men
realistic as technology gets better so
eventually you'll be able to play any
instrument from the greatest instrument
of all the piano check mate
but now that I'm done ripping on every
other musician let me just say this I'll
hope you guys is not lost us pianists
have one person and theirs
[Music]
you